I am humble tollens honey boo sodomy ale
it's a translation for that is that
means I'm curry and as a proud Korean
that means I have a deep yearning
connection with my home countries my
mother lands my mother's lands what a
Korean is known for yeah that too but
also and most importantly beauty beauty
products when we were in Korea we
actually bought a bunch of these Amy
took me to the store called big Korean
now is Beauty barn bonanza so I have a
variety of face masks face lifting
things nose things which things my
things masks this torture device masks
pts masks and mess so I'm gonna start
because I obviously know what I'm doing
hold on to sauce why is it wet what a
face mask need to be wet your face don't
you have to be wet wait which way does
it go on my face well you have to peel
it off if it's already wet why wouldn't
it just be there do we stick the peel
side on my face there like an active
ingredient in this how smooth is my ski
woo-wee
that's a texture Oh cha that means I'd
like so this is puss
I feel like Dwight truth when he cuts
off the dummy's face don't look at my
tips I'm sure there are instructions on
here of how long you're supposed to keep
this on but there's only three pictures
here and the middle one shows a clock
that either goes fifteen minutes or
three hours I can't quite tell it takes
up a quarter of the time circle thing
clock is wholly on me that's cat totem
Monteagle sheep button p blue doll puss
okay yes box greens don't believe in
scissors
[Music]
what's that
oh the delivery bird from The Hunger
Games is here you yeah
no don't look maybe do I know how to put
this on okay I'm working through it let
me do it very large you know put this
robe on like backwards because I'm
having to nip exposure problems exactly
it's a bit
can I get chicken attendees mom wait
[Music]
yeah catch ow all right we opened up the
BTS one oh yeah oh okay it's just step
one of the kit
step two of the kid step three step
lover who is buying this to get the
exclusive postcards so they come with
their own face masks we've got nmf
aquarium fuel mask X thousand English
we've got tea tree care solution
essential mask eggs
okay that was words why is it wet why is
it so what it's so wet
it's it's so goopy it's like snot it's
like someone's knee
it's like someone did something other
than sneezing it under this BTS
why would someone look forward to this
cuz I imagine people would be like I
can't wait to go home what about my BG s
mask look at the books
for this Korean that are known for their
facial hair or body hair beautiful I'm
only in the second mask why are you
laughing
I'm not gonna bother with all these
because I think I get the general gist
of it that's what you wanted right I
feel a natural inclination to push my
lips out farther this is why super
Shepard had the accent he did because I
felt like I needed to do this to get my
lip acting in there so I also have my
hands are so covered in BTS semen that I
can't actually grab this or you I forgot
oh God like all my problems in life
might eat us all look at this lady on
the back zoom in on this and my life
alright so this is live so I won't be
able to talk for a while so I'm going to
have subtitled all of my actual thoughts
afterwards okay it's no blank it's the
field a pristine meadow of untouched
white no animals calm no birds cry only
the steady rustling of wind through dead
trees accented by the impact of his axe
a crack like thunder rings out as the
ancient pine finally succumbs to his
murderous assault the old giant crashes
into the ground Jamie anyway now it's
time to move
I feel beautiful okay I'm going back
this looks stupid doesn't it my tits my
tits breast mask I've got this because I
want my boobs to be as subtle as
possible
I should have shaved but I didn't so
it's like an obstacle course for the
mask which seems right stick anyway I
don't know why specifically you want
your boobs to be moisturized and no
other part of you but uh but I feel a
cool tingling sensation so that's nice
so this also comes with a associated
building methods see these aren't wet
these aren't wet they're dry
why is this gonna like menthol now see
I'm getting out of frame here for a
second I have to bellybuttons because I
had surgery that went in down here
laparoscopically
so I have to make a choice which belly
button I want I'm gonna go for big Bongo
I'm happy
can this be the Sunday law will be
instantly Devon oh no my face is livid
alright so those are tingly man if only
buddha had this in his time
alright so there's this other thing it's
like a it's like a lifting mask so when
your chin gets real droopy i guess cuz
the bone has a tendency to wander over
time so you want to make sure that chin
stays in place where it belongs so you
have these masks that kind of stretch
underneath your chin to give you a
lifting sensation or something like that
does this like hook over my ears or what
okay my head's huge so i don't know how
well they're gonna work but no pain no
gain to my right dude i'm ebonne day
don't move that sounds like a being
racist I'm not making fun of the Korean
language I'm reading it hi I have this
thing called the smile maker yeah it's
called the smile maker now this looks
like an anatomical drawing of users am I
wrong so you're supposed to bite down
hard on this this the u-shaped parts
into each side of the mouth
uh-huh so I reflected on those
underneath and just could help you have
runners file where this product three
times a day just for one I also had this
green tea no [ __ ] no that shuts out the
gunk in your pores oh yeah assisting
that subtractive dunking your [ __ ] to
continue towards things so this is the
crease plan forget it you gonna DeLuna
right so this is our concern you or the
culture shallow integrity and honor okay
they're just fun you're learning out so
I don't know what they mean by brighter
smile
it's my smile brighter okay anyway um so
cut the strawberries [ __ ] this who says
it's a mask sheet slice mask sheet
they're cute right
ah to my eyes he was drifting up into my
eyes must be my magnetic personality
am i beautiful okay cool I think I can
take this off now my chin feels properly
lived in I don't know what effect this
is supposed to be it doesn't even feel
like it's tight
look none of these products feel like
they're doing anything I like it when
something hits my skin that it burns it
feels like it's melting and that way
it works it's like mouthwash you only
know what it working when it hurts
they say beauty is pain but this is easy
I've got a moisture foot pack but for
the sake of all the foot fetish shoes
out there I'm not going to do that
everybody knows the hands are the foots
of the hands so this is a foot mask but
to thwart all the foot fetish assists
I miss visit diaper this looks like a
diaper this is a diaper
nothing convinces me this is not a
diaper everything about this is
screaming diaper I hit the wet spot
[Music]
putting your hand inside a dead animal
this is a moist goopy dead animal that's
cold it's rum reasons implicating me in
a lot of sticking my hand in dead
animals but okay I've never stuck my
hand in a dead animal this is the first
thing that jumped into mind it's like
sticking your hand in a used diaper
that's been left out sitting for a while
so it got cold and I don't know if I'd
rather have a warm diaper or a cold
diaper right now I'd want to try a warm
diaper just to get some kind of
difference so I can compare I don't know
how it could be better with your feet
hey I think the internet would kill me
if I didn't about this mask
all right Shrek try the mystery Shrek
oh yeah if both doesn't feel any
different than the other masks and it
feels completely different from the
other masks but I think that's just a
sense of power have we ever introduced
Henri
oh this is Henry okay bye honey
chica girl oh good you're okay so good
good girl okay yeah so this is Henry and
chica
do you remember me you recognize me we
need to be the BTS give me one whack for
yes we are for hell yes I kick these off
okay okay you're not gonna like this no
you wanna say yes if you want to be
[Music]
or beautiful Henry do you wanna mess wow
so pretty so unbelievable so so pretty
all right good girl thank you sure could
be so goddamn cute too pretty that's too
precious all right so there's only one
thing left to try so this is a Zig
bubble clay mask when it reacts with air
it's all bubbly okay so this is the
bubble mask so when you put this on your
face it starts to bubble up and since I
can't see anything I can only go by
sensation but I've got this weird
tingling tickling sensation going all
across my nose so with that being said I
guess I can rate my favorite masks I
definitely like the breast mask I'm not
just saying that because I like boobs
I'm saying that because it wasn't
sopping wet when I first put it on it
had a nice menthol to it so I knew it
was working because I could feel it
tingle on my titties and then I actually
had the belly mask on and I could really
smell the menthol and that worked out
well so I like that this lifting thing I
have no idea how that's even supposed to
how they even think that supposed to
work I don't know it's its slogan is my
special secret of jaw line management
and I didn't know how much jaw line
management I needed in my day-to-day
life but now I have some as opposed to
zero so I suppose that's good
these are horrible BTS Dreamboats
thank you for so much moisture
those things didn't grab anything these
cute as a [ __ ] button look a trick my
god it's okay smile brightener the smile
maker I don't know I'm not gonna stick
this in my mouth again too because it's
covered in many different fluids now and
then I will cherish these till the end
of my days
I'll hang them up above my bed and I
will enjoy them in my privacy of my own
home I mask I like those
those are cool they were like gel not
very cost-effective the only give one
that's stupid unless you're supposed to
reuse them why can't you reuse these put
more liquid on yeah it's like that's
like printer ink that's what that is
it says the whole beauty market is like
printer ink is cement you too bye bye
bye things that may be work not purred
by the FDA who's made Korea they don't
even have FDA who knows what the worst
but considering this is all part of my
proud proud proud heritage I'm gonna
just pray to my BTS tribe and asked my
mom why the hell I bought all these the
take away is the price of beauty is high
and the price of beauty is higher if you
buy a hundred and twenty dollars worth
of it in Korea and then bring it with
you back home to try for a video so
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you for staying beautiful and if
you want to stay beautiful
I've got no tips for you so look
somewhere else other than me but if
you've got other cool things that you
want me to try out whether it's beauty
products makeup different toys other
gadgets candy from other countries food
from other countries let me know it out
in the comments below I wouldn't mind
trying new things every week or so so
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out the other cool crazy stuff
that I've done in the description or in
the suggested videos over there so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye